[Music]
I mean, mom, this store is
wonderful, you don't have to pay here, it's really nice to
help,
we moved, we needed our
things, and we really didn't have anything,
I came here while I was pregnant and it's really
good, but a lot of help,
I came again to look for some
things for the new room
we are in roots which is a
foundation created to help
venezuelans recently arrived in the us who
arrive with nothing
whatever they can donate that we
think can help her
i had two companies in venezuela I
worked with typical sweets  my country
and I also had a business called help and
fashion boutique accessories makeup
we had a very
large used clothing business
but from a time when the
economy is so crazy then
very strong although it is a business that was already
profitable at one time  has
moved and now we are no longer enough
to close ourselves 10
[Music]
of being hard-working people to close everything
because  e 17 hours and 12 hours without ducts we
couldn't work and my dad is
sick medicine is not available in venezuela
we have to look for it in cúcuta when in
venezuela they earn us 4 dollars a month
in a loose change and they spend 50 for my dad's medicine
dollars and it is weekly and I
personally have 27 years of
experience I have always worked in
banking I have a degree in administration I
was a bank manager and I currently
work here in the US for software
here and relatively I am working
for a company that works with a
brand of coffee
and  Well, things are going very well for me and I'm very grateful
to them.
I already have all my family in Venezuela.
I'm the first in the family group to
show that. So that was a song that
I swear to you.
[Music] It
's pure because my family, my mom, and
well that's how.  I start talking about it,
it always hits me
and it left them in a very difficult situation
because my dad and mom are
elderly and the situation is not given
either for them to be able to work  r
my sisters and I are the ones who
support him
and basically the reason for my leaving
my daughter and her
and more force to leave my country to leave all
my children this country that has many
opportunities for them
and it feels empty to be and my  family
here this is every day the
memories are painful but inside
me there is something positive and I tell
them every day that we see it that
I am not with them but yes and they
are always present in me and I help them to
here working economically for them
but my country on the ground is very sad
and shattered
socialism I never work one knows
a socialist who has a business a
flourishing or positive or good company
that provides employment that produces that believes
they are never only politicians who speak
only
you say  say a house in this country the
beginning of your future and that's why
you have to be a touch of love
working in physical stores this guy
place by doctors a space solar and pain
in the rain of the  universe
juana y con to display sana y midi
families and win me correntinos
[Música]
comeback with drums of press
neighbors enjoy it and remember that
you are receiving this little gift from a
grateful person who received many little
gifts when I need them fabulous
hope that if you have security and you have
a good deal the
pension institutions here are not going to go well
your life is all that you left
behind these opportunities that will be here
because they couldn't give it there
[Music]
I would tell the Americans that
we are good people that we love
help them to work and to continue
helping this country to be
bigger every day better
[Music]
very rich
I think that when you are a grandmother all the
children of silk are also your grandchildren
when you see us sad you are sad and
when you see them happy you are happy
it is an emotion that you would like to show yourself
which is what it says look what you are
doing
very rich I think that these are
very pleasant moments for me
what I pa  only here